SCP-096, the Shy Guy, woke up in an unfamiliar
room without a thought in its head.
However, one thing quickly occurred to it:
This was not its containment chamber.
No, the solid steel cube that had kept it
locked up for decades now didn’t have a
front desk, or walls covered in strange, childlike
murals, or tinny party music playing over
old speakers.
Wherever SCP-096 had found itself, it certainly
wasn’t the place it’d come to call home.
If it could read, it would have registered
the word’s behind the front desk, painted
onto the wall: Banban’s Kindergarten - Where
joy comes alive!
Little did 096 know, something really did
come to life here at Banban’s kindergarten,
but it wasn’t definitely joy.
SCP-096 was typically used to a much more
confined space, so presented with so much
strange freedom, its natural instinct was
to wander around, whimpering quietly to itself.
This place was certainly peculiar, with multiple
large, reinforced doors, each one having a
large, red button fixed to the wall above
them.
A strange green creature was painted on the
wall, with an affixed speech bubble that read,
“Jumbo Josh says, ‘Eat fruits and vegetables
if you want to be strong like me!’”
Though 096 paid no mind to such things.
This place looked like an SCP Foundation containment
facility mixed with an off-brand Chuck E Cheese,
and some tiny part of the Shy Guy’s dim
and dismal brain wanted to see more of it.
What other secrets could it hold?
The Shy Guy pressed one of the big red buttons,
causing the doors to open underneath it.
There was a faint sound of childish laughter
somewhere down the distant hall.
How had it ever found its way to such a strange
place?
The deeper the Shy Guy wandered, the more
strange murals it saw on the wall.
There was one for a large, orange cartoon
jellyfish with one staring eye, where the
speech bubble read, “Stinger Flynn says,
‘Having many arms allows me to help a lot
of people.’”
Then, a squat, blue gorilla-like creature
with sharp lower teeth, the speech bubble
reading, “Captain Fiddles says, ’Ooga
Booga!
Booga ooga!’”
A White, feminine, cat-like creature had the
speech bubble, “Banbaleena says, ‘Kindness
is free, so sprinkle it everywhere.’”
A misshapen, pink bird creature had the speech
bubble, “Opila Bird says, ‘Laughter is
the best medicine, so make sure to smile.’”
And of course, most importantly of all, presiding
over the “creativity room”, was a mural
of a grinning red creature wearing a pair
of party hats on his head like horns.
His speech bubble read, “Banban says, ‘Sharing
is caring.
Your pancreas is mine!’”
A whiteboard not far from this mural had the
words, “RUN FOR YOUR LIVES!”
hastily scrawled onto it.
To anyone but the Shy Guy, who had no point
of reference, this was clearly not a normal
Kindergarten.
As the Shy Guy passed into the hallway, slowly
lumbering along, it suddenly felt an intense
spike of burning pain right through its forehead.
Rising like a fever pitch, the Shy Guy’s
subdued whimpers quickly escalated into horrifying
wails of animal rage.
This could only mean one thing: Somewhere,
something had made the terrible mistake of
gazing at the Shy Guy’s face.
In fact, not ten feet away, the unfortunate
Opila Bird had made that very mistake.
It typically peeked out from behind one of
the hallway’s pillars to get a good look
at any potential intruders, or new prey wandering
into its midst.
But this time, the beastly bird’s curiosity
had taken it from predator to prey itself.
Though it wouldn’t realize this until it
was already too late.
As the mutant bird creature skittered back
into the cavernous hall filled with plastic
trees and an underwhelming play area, the
Shy Guy came galloping after it on all fours,
roaring with fury.
The Opila Bird was shocked to see the creature
giving chase - This doesn’t make sense,
I’m meant to chase you, you’re not meant
to chase me!
But things are rarely fair when it comes to
the Shy Guy - arguably one of the most dangerous
Euclid-class creatures ever kept in Foundation
containment.
The Opila Bird flapped desperately towards
the boarded-up escape hatch, but the Shy Guy
was so much faster.
It grabbed hold of the bird, gripping it in
its iron clutches, and began to stretch open
its bottom jaw with a blood-curdling roar.
We’ll spare you the details of what happened
next, but suffice to say, little more than
a handful of feathers were left.
After finishing off the Opila Bird, the Shy
Guy reverted from rage back to pitiful sadness.
This place was no better than the SCP Foundation
- There were still creatures here to look
at its face and drive it into a state of extreme
emotional distress!
It was horrible.
The Shy Guy needed to find a way to hide himself
away again, so he decided to tear away the
planks covering up the escape hatch and lope
down the narrow hall.
In there, the Shy Guy actually found something
to its liking: Two platforms, one on either
side of the room, with what seemed to be a
deep, dark chasm between the two.
For most, there was an electrical lift system
for carrying them between the platforms, but
the Shy Guy had no interest in the platforms
- He only sought the darkness below, where
nobody could see his face.
That would suit him just fine.
The Shy Guy jumped over the guard rail and
plummeted down below into the dark.
Feeling the air against its cold, gray skin
as it fell felt wonderful.
It dared to think that it might even find
solace in this deep, dark place, but as soon
as it hit something solid - Some kind of metal
lift system - alarms went off, and flashing
red lights soon made everything down there
in the darkness visible.
To be exposed like this while it thought it
was hidden was the dreaded Shy Guy’s worst
nightmare.
Little did he know, he would soon become the
worst nightmare of a number of other beasts.
As the Shy Guy crawled off the metal platform,
hoping that perhaps it could find another
place to hide down here, its hands and feet
splashed into shallow water.
Had something sprung a leak down here?
The Shy Guy began wandering the half-dark
as the water of this flooded sub-basement
area, having no idea that another creature
was already sneaking up behind it, getting
ready to strike.
Before 096 could even react, several whip-like
orange tentacles wrapped around its limbs
and began delivering an agonizing shock through
its body.
More tentacles came in soon after, wrapping
around the Shy Guy’s body and face, delivering
shock after shock after shock with its millions
of tiny, venomous stinger barbs.
For a second, it seemed like the surprise
attack might actually be able to subdue the
monster, but little did the Shy Guy’s attacker
- the monstrous real Stinger Flynn - know,
that attacking it was just another way to
activate its infamous rage state.
The second that Stinger Flynn relented, even
for just a moment, the Shy Guy grabbed him
by the tentacles and slammed him into the
watery floor, again and again and again, until
the grip of his tentacles loosened around
the Shy Guy’s body, and he was defenseless.
With Stinger panicked and immobilized, the
Shy Guy released the full force of his supernatural
fury, striking the demonic jellyfish with
his fists until what was left couldn’t be
distinguished from the water it used to be
floating in.
Stinger Flynn had been completely annihilated.
The Shy Guy, once again temporarily returned
to a state of calm, wandered out of this watery
basement into a nearby hallway, where everything
was bright and dry.
The walls were painted in garish, childlike
drawings of a jungle with janky-looking animals.
The Shy Guy paid no mind to any of it - All
he wanted was to find somewhere that he could
actually be alone, and away from the prying
eyes of all these freaks.
This dream was short-lived, because as soon
as the Shy Guy found a new room - A wide-open
auditorium filled with inflatable jungle trees,
like a crude play area - he was being stalked
yet again.
A powerful, muscular predator, with veins
stretching over its bulging muscles and blue
skin.
It knew that this intruder had already killed
two of its fellow Garten dwellers, but this
time, it would put this spindly, pale stranger
in its place.
The Shy Guy heard something rumbling towards
it from behind, and turned upon hearing the
bloodcurdling war cry of “Ooga booga, booga
ooga!”
It was the gorilla-like Captain Fiddles, with
strands of saliva hanging from his tusks.
He leaped onto the Shy Guy and began pounding
into its hideous face with his huge, blue
fists.
Captain Fiddles would destroy the Shy Guy,
pound him into the concrete until he stopped
moving.
The one thing that Captain Fiddles didn’t
expect was for the Shy Guy to start fighting
back - And he was about to learn the hard
truth that the Shy Guy could fight a lot harder
than him.
The SCP’s spindly but immensely powerful
arms grabbed Captain Fiddles by the shoulders
and threw him into the wall, causing huge
cracks to crawl up toward the ceiling.
Before Captain Fiddles could even think about
wrenching himself free, the Shy Guy leaped
to his feet and bounded over to him.
The Shy Guy grabbed Captain Fiddles by the
ankles and ripped him out of the wall, letting
his body drop to the floor and then unleashing
hell upon him.
Captain Fiddles would have begged for mercy,
if he wasn’t already dead.
Before the Shy Guy could even begin to calm
down, a trap door opened in the floor beneath
him, dropping him into a new area: A multi-colored
maze, where 096 was trapped like a helpless
rat…
With the body count of an atom bomb.
Once again, the Shy Guy didn’t need to go
looking for trouble, because trouble was already
on its way: The pure white, catlike Banbaleena
pounced from a sharp corner in the maze, claws
bared.
She jumped onto the Shy Guy, latching onto
him and clawing at him, trying to scratch
his nightmare of a face.
If the Shy Guy had ever possessed anything
resembling patience, it would have run out
long before now.
It grabbed Banbaleena, shrugging off the pain
of her claws, and tossed her into the darkness
high above.
She flew off with a cat-like yowl and hit
some distant ceiling with a crunch.
Suffice to say, she wouldn’t be back to
bother the Shy Guy again.
Tired and angry, the pale abomination didn’t
feel like wandering through a maze.
Instead, it just charged straight through,
destroying colorful wall after colorful wall.
When it encountered whatever was behind this
extremely frustrating afternoon, it would
destroy it with extreme prejudice.
That was almost a certainty.
After breaking through one more wall, the
Shy Guy tumbled out into a storage room, where
a grinning red creature was waiting for him
- Wearing two party hats on top of his head.
This was no mere lackey, it was Banban himself,
the one behind this nightmarish kindergarten.
He stared right into the Shy Guy’s face
with no fear at all, almost like he knew something
the Shy Guy didn’t.
And it was true - He had no plan to fight
the Shy Guy himself.
He’d brought a champion with him.
As the Shy Guy started to scream in rage,
all the boxes behind Banban tumbled out of
the way as a huge figure rose.
A behemoth, at least fifty feet tall, with
green skin, giant teeth, and huge, staring
eyes.
It was Jumbo Josh, and if the Shy Guy wanted
to graduate from this nightmare kindergarten,
it would need to defeat him and Banban.
Shy Guy growled, digging its claws into the
ground and preparing to charge forward.
Challenge accepted.
Now go check out “SCP-096 - Look at a Picture
of Shy Guy in Space?
The Shy Guy Questions and Theories” and
“SCP-049 Cures SCP-096 of the Pestilence?!”
for more!